Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Britlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 127.
Ausgabe von UKW vom 6. November 2024.
Und das Datum wird euch sicherlich gleich erzählen, was gerade passiert ist.
Die US-Wahl ist durch und sieht ganz so aus,
als ob der Worst Case eingetreten ist und wir wollten uns ohnehin hier nochmal zusammensetzen,
der Pavel und ich und ich sage hallo zu Pavel.
Hallo Tim, hallo.
Also um mal wieder die Situation der Ukraine zusammenzufassen,
da hat sich nämlich so im letzten Monat, also wir beide haben jetzt zusammen am 25.
September, also etwas mehr als einen Monatsletzte Mal die Situation zusammengefasst
und seitdem ist im Prinzip gar nicht so viel passiert. Was passiert ist,
werden wir gleich nochmal zusammenfassen.
Und ja, und jetzt ist eben auch noch die US-Wahl durch und das wird natürlich
nicht ohne Konsequenzen bleiben für die Situation hier.
Und darüber wollen wir natürlich dann auch ausführlich sprechen.
Das wird sicherlich eine sehr energetische Sendung werden heute.
Ich würde sagen, wir bleiben erstmal bei unserem bewährten Konzept und machen
erstmal einen Rückblick, was eigentlich passiert ist und dann schauen wir,
was demnächst wohl vermutlich noch so passieren wird.
Gut, also blicken wir erstmal in die Ukraine und ja, zuletzt,
also wir hatten unsere letzte Sendung am 25.
September, ich habe ja dann mit Enno nochmal eine Sendung aufgenommen,
der in der Ukraine war, ein weiteres Mal und Short Notice und dort an die östliche
Front gefahren ist und von dort berichtet hat.
Wer das noch nicht gehört hat, mag da gerne nochmal nachhören.
Das war auf jeden Fall alles sehr interessant.
Und da kam aber auch schon deutlich zur Sprache, dass der Druck auf die Ukraine,
der militärische Druck durch die Russen enorm zunimmt gerade.
Und das ist jetzt im Prinzip auch eigentlich das Thema der letzten vier,
fünf Wochen gewesen in militärischer Hinsicht.
Russland, so scheint es, hat quasi alles nach vorne geworfen,
was sich irgendwie nach vorne werfen lässt.
Das kann man auch daran sehen, dass die Verluste, die Russland gehabt hat,
die höchsten waren in den letzten zwei Monaten.
Wenn man so schaut, wie viele Casualties es nach den Berichten gab pro Woche,
stieg das einfach bis auf über 10.000 pro Woche an.
Die Zahl ist natürlich keine...
Wie soll ich sagen, beweisbare Zahl. Sie ist aber in gewisser Hinsicht belastbar,
als dass diese Zählweise so schon seit Beginn des Krieges gemacht wird und eigentlich
vielen Vergleichen in etwa standgehalten hat.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass von diesen Casualties, also von diesen Verlusten,
ungefähr zwei Drittel Verletzungen sind.
Also dass Leute quasi aus dem Krieg genommen werden, weil sie einfach schwer
verwundet werden und ein Drittel sind dann natürlich Tote, vielleicht sind es auch ein paar mehr.
Auf jeden Fall sind das eben Verluste in der Hinsicht, als dass sie eben danach
nicht unmittelbar wieder auf dem Schlachtfeld zum Einsatz kommen.
Ja, plus ein paar Kriegsgefangene.
Richtig, genau. Die Zahl deckt das natürlich auch noch mit ab,
wobei ich glaube Kriegsgefangene gab es wohl vermutlich nur so in Kursk in größerer Menge.
An der alten Front sozusagen, also in der Ukraine liegenden Front dürfte das eher die Ausnahme sein.
Dazu kommt, dass gerade in letzter Zeit die Berichte von gefangenen ukrainischen
Soldaten, die dann wiederum gleich auch nachdem sie gefangen wurden,
getötet wurden, auch stark zugenommen hat.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nichts, was man jetzt irgendwie mit Zahlen belegen kann,
nur die Zahl der Berichte darüber hat stark zugenommen.
Also der Krieg wird weiterhin sehr blutig geführt auf beiden Seiten und vor
allem dadurch, dass eben Russland herzlich wenig gibt auf die eigenen Truppen.
Da werden die Leute einfach verheizt, so wie das eigentlich von Anfang an schon der Fall ist.
Aber die letzten Wochen haben sozusagen auch nochmal das, was schon beim Kampf
um Avdivka und den Bachmut schon so extrem war, nochmal ein weiteres Mal gesteigert.
Ja, plus es liegt halt daran, dass sie jetzt nicht nur versucht haben,
an ein oder zwei Stellen jetzt in die Offensive zu gehen,
sondern eigentlich entlang eines Großteils der Frontlinie,
eigentlich so auf zwei Dritteln der Frontlinie, eigentlich sind sie in die Offensive
gegangen und dadurch kommt natürlich auch eine Menge zusammen jetzt.
Genau, das ist vor allem der gesamte östliche Teil, also wenn man die Frontlinie quasi so top down,
wenn man auf die Ukraine schaut, dann verläuft halt ein Teil so von Norden nach
Süden, stark im Osten eben und von dort geht es dann mehr oder weniger gerade
nach Westen durch Saborigia.
Da ist relativ wenig los und dann kommt ja auch schon dieses Dnipro-Becken,
was jetzt gar kein Becken mehr ist, sondern mehr so eine Sumpflandschaft,
wo halt der Fluss irgendwo durchfließt und natürlich dann der Mündungsbereich bei Kherson.
Da ist es also vergleichsweise ruhig, auch wenn dort natürlich Angriffe stattfinden,
vor allem auf die Stadt Kherson, wo also die Russen im Prinzip permanent so
einen Terror machen und mit drohenden Zivilisten in der Stadt jagen etc.
Auch alles sehr unangenehm, was dort passiert.
Aber es hat sich sozusagen konzentriert auf ein paar Hotspots.
Das ist halt der immerwährende Versuch der Russen, irgendwelche Strongholds
der Ukraine abzuräumen. Im Nordosten drückt man halt auf die Stadt Krupiansk,
da hat sich nicht so viel getan.
Dann gibt es etwas weiter südlicher den Frontverlauf, wo nach der Kharkiv-Offensive
der Ukrainer, ja die Ukrainer so...
Land jenseits des Ostkiel-Flusses genommen hat und da so eine Bufferzone von
10 Kilometern hat, da ist es den Russen an einer Stelle gelungen,
nahezu komplett durchzubrechen und so ein bisschen den Frontverlauf für die
Ukraine dort in zwei Teile zu teilen, sowas ist immer sehr gefährlich und,
dann ist der Vorstoß auf die Stadt Prokowsk.
Weitergegangen, es sind weitere Orte genommen worden,
Man ist jetzt noch nicht unbedingt direkt vor Pokrovsk, aber sehr viel Puffer ist da nicht mehr.
Andererseits sind dort aber auch die Verteidigungslinien dann wiederum nochmal sehr viel stärker.
Also wir werden jetzt keinen Fall dieser Stadt in naher Zukunft sehen,
aber trotzdem ist die Landnahme fortwährend.
Und auch ein anderer Stronghold, der jetzt zwei Jahre gehalten hat,
nämlich die Stadt Wuleda, ein Ort, wo die Russen unheimlich viele Verluste erlitten
haben in den letzten zwei Jahren, auch das war jetzt von der Ukraine nicht mehr
zu halten und musste aufgegeben werden.
Das klingt jetzt alles ganz dramatisch, ist es natürlich im Prinzip auch,
nur wenn man sich das eben jetzt rein von der Landnahme anschaut,
wie viel Prozent des ukrainischen Geländes konnten die Russen mit diesem riesigen
Aufwand, mit der Opferung von nahezu 300.000 Personen in diesem Jahr allein gewinnen.
Das ist halt alles immer noch sehr wenig. Also der Widerstand der Ukraine ist enorm.
Und obwohl die Verluste natürlich stark sind, sind jetzt die Gewinne auch nicht
so, wo man sagen könnte, ja, jetzt müssen sie noch hier und da reinpiksen und
da nochmal ein bisschen aufdrehen und dann überlaufen sie die Ukraine.
Das wird so nicht passieren. Das ist halt nach wie vor nicht passiert.
Nicht realistisch, es sei denn, und dazu werden wir natürlich später noch kommen,
die Unterstützung der Ukraine bricht ein oder die Sanktionen gegen die Russen
werden in irgendeiner Form zurückgefahren.
Beides Dinge, die natürlich jetzt drohen.
Ja, ansonsten sind viel kleinere Maßnahmen noch beobachtet worden.
Es gab ein paar Berichte von abgeschossenen SU-34-Kampfflugzeugen der Russen,
wo russische Quellen behauptet haben,
das seien jetzt die F-16-Bomber der Ukraine gewesen, die ihnen geliefert wurden.
Da gab es überhaupt gar keine Bestätigung für in irgendeiner Form.
Habe ich jetzt auch so nicht mit gerechnet, weil selbst wenn es so ist,
werden die Ukrainer da schön leise zu sein und nicht verraten,
mit welcher Technik sie jetzt irgendwelche Erfolge gehabt haben.
Andererseits ist der Drohnenkrieg, den die Ukraine dort entfacht hat, weiter in vollem Gange.
Also nicht nur, dass jetzt die Ukraine mit Drohnen unterwegs ist,
das sind natürlich die Russen auch, aber die Ukraine hat an der Stelle wirklich
einen Vorteil, weil sie einfach mit der Produktion da besser rankommen,
insbesondere mit der Produktion im eigenen Land.
Und sie werden immer findiger, was neue Varianten und neue Modelle betrifft.
Also sie sind in der Lage, ihre Springkraft zu erhöhen, sie sind in der Lage,
ihre Fernsteuerung zu verbessern, sie sind in der Lage, unabhängiger vom Electronic
Warfare, also von dem Jamming zu werden.
Die Reichweiten sind stark gestiegen und so gelingt es ihnen immer wieder,
größere Ziele zu treffen.
Am letzten Mal hatten wir ja diese Erfolge mit der Bombardierung der Militärlager gehabt,
der Munitionslager gehabt und das ist ein bisschen zurückgegangen,
es gab einen weiteren Angriff, der nicht so gut gelaufen ist,
da weiß man nicht so ganz genau, ob ihnen jetzt die Munition ausgegangen ist
oder ob die Russen in irgendeiner Form eine Methode gefunden haben,
sich da besser zu verteidigen,
sowas wie mal die Waffen tatsächlich in den Bunker räumen oder solche Tricks.
Andererseits sind größere Öldepots auch noch vernichtet worden durch die Ukraine.
Das wird am Ende jetzt nicht den entscheidenden einzelnen Faktor auslösen,
aber das ist natürlich etwas, wo Russland auch weiterhin geschwächt wird und
davon abgehalten wird, weiter aufzudrehen.
Ja, und die große Nachricht ist natürlich, dass jetzt nicht nur,
die russische Armee in der Ukraine kämpft, sondern dass sich Russland und Nordkorea
wohl offenbar darauf geeinigt haben, auch nordkoreanische Soldaten zu entsenden
und das ist wirklich eine wilde Story.
Also es wurde relativ früh davon berichtet,
dass von Nordkorea nordkoreanische Soldaten per Schiff nach Russland kamen und
dann später vermutlich mal per Zug in die Ukraine ins Kursgebiet gebracht wurden.
Und es gibt mittlerweile auch genug Videomaterial, was das eindeutig belegt.
Ja und offenbar versucht Russland seinen Personalmangel durch so eine Art Deal
mit Nordkorea zu kompensieren.
Wie genau dieser Deal ist, das wissen wir natürlich nicht.
Aber es wird irgendwas sein zwischen, wir helfen, also wir geben euch eine Menge
Geld, aber es wird auch gemunkelt, dass Hilfe beim Waffenbau etc.
Mit dabei sein könnte. Was auch immer, es hat offensichtlich den Kim Jong-un dazu gebracht,
hier Blutsbruderschaft mit Russland zu beschwören und einfach mal so ein paar
Soldaten seiner riesigen Armee abzutreten.
Wie gut die jetzt ausgebildet sind, ob es sich dabei um Spezialtruppen oder
um normale Rekruten oder in irgendeiner Form weiter ausgebildete Soldaten handelt,
das wissen wir nicht, wird sich zeigen.
Allerdings wird allgemein auch vermutet, dass, naja, also erstmal 10.000,
das ist so die Zahl, die wir derzeit an wöchentlichen Casualties haben.
Also im Prinzip reicht das quasi bei der aktuellen Intensität der Kämpfe quasi mal so für eine Woche.
Nicht, dass die jetzt alle Nordkoreaner auf einmal Hops nehmen werden,
aber so von der, wenn das sozusagen eine Verstärkung sein soll,
dann wird das halt nicht lange reichen.
Dass die Nordkoreaner jetzt militärisch da in irgendeiner Form eine nennenswerte
Verbesserung darstellen, das wird eigentlich allgemein bezweifelt.
Und einfach weil hier natürlich zwei Welten aufeinandertreffen,
die so sehr die Politiker da auch ihre Verbundenheit beschwören,
wenig miteinander zu tun haben.
Also erstmal ist da natürlich die Sprache und gerade Nordkoreaner sind natürlich
auch nochmal besonders sprachlich isoliert.
Nicht nur weil kaum jemand Koreanisch spricht, es ist halt auch so,
dass das Koreanisch, was in Nordkorea gesprochen wird, auch nochmal ganz anders
ist oder sich zumindest auch deutlich anders entwickelt hat.
Als das in Südkorea, also wenn überhaupt haben Südkoreaner da eine Chance,
das zu verstehen, aber dass Russland überhaupt genug Übersetzer findet,
die dort in den Kampfgebieten das...
Die Kommunikation zwischen diesen nordkoreanischen Truppen und den russischen
Truppen aufrecht, das kann schon mal stark bezweifelt werden.
Und dazu kommt natürlich, dass auch diese Truppen jetzt mit Equipment ausgestattet
werden sollen und da haben die Russen ja selber schon nicht von genug.
Also da gibt es schon einige Berichte von Auseinandersetzungen,
dass irgendwie aufeinander geschossen wurde,
dass da halt die Russen irgendwie mit ihrem anti-asiatischen Rassismus,
den sie ja ohnehin im Land haben, denen begegnet sind.
Andere berichten, dass Koreaner nicht in der Lage sind, Freund und Feind auseinander
zu halten, weil die können den Unterschied zwischen einem Russen und einem Ukrainer nicht festmachen.
Ja, also die können nicht irgendwie sagen, sag mal Pallianizia und dann wissen
sie, wer wer ist, sondern das sind einfach nochmal ganz andere Probleme.
Also was das alles bewirken wird, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel,
aber Tatsache ist, dass wir jetzt hier so einen weiteren Weltkrieg Aspekt haben,
in dem halt jetzt einfach mal ein komplett anderes Land mit in diesen Krieg eingreift.
Also anders ausgedrückt, Nordkorea greift Europa an.
Ja, also seit Genghis Khan gab es irgendwie keine asiatischen Gruppen mehr in Europa. Aber wohl, ja,
das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall eine bedenkliche Eskalation und führt dann potenziell auch dazu,
dass Südkorea natürlich auch reagieren wird, Wobei die halt explizit auch erstmal
nicht angekündigt haben,
Waffen direkt zu liefern an die Ukraine jetzt und wollten eben auch die Wahlen abwarten.
Ja, genau. Da muss man erstmal schauen, was das hierzu bringt.
Ja und damit sind wir eigentlich schon bei der Politik.
Also die letzten Wochen waren eher davon geprägt, dass Zelensky viel unterwegs
war und seinen Verbündeten seinen sogenannten Victory Plan näher gebracht hat.
Also eine strategische Ausarbeitung, wie die Ukraine das so sieht,
was jetzt eigentlich notwendig wäre, um hier einen Sieg der Ukraine zu sichern.
Und, tja, ich würde mal sagen, der wurde zurückhaltend aufgenommen,
wahrscheinlich aus denselben Gründen.
Trotzdem vielleicht mal wertvoll kurz drauf zu schauen, was dieser Plan denn
eigentlich, was diesen Plan im Wesentlichen ausmacht.
Und es gibt da auch eine schöne Analyse von diesem Anders Puck Nielsen,
der halt das so im Wesentlichen in so fünf Teile aufgeteilt hat.
Und Kernforderung zunächst einmal ist, dass die Ukraine eine Einladung zu einer
NATO-Mitgliedschaft erhält.
Damit ist man nicht automatisch in der NATO, aber das erlaubt sozusagen auch
eine andere politische Kette dann abzulaufen.
Und in dem Moment, wo so etwas ausgesprochen wäre, müsste man sich sozusagen
um die nächsten Schritte unterhalten und nicht über den ersten Schritt. Und.
Ich finde das auch sehr angemessen, weil ich denke, die Zukunft der Ukraine muss in der NATO liegen.
Was jetzt die Zukunft der NATO betrifft, das wird sicherlich gleich nochmal
ein eigenes Thema werden, aber
das ist sozusagen jetzt hier in diesem Plan der erste Schritt gewesen.
Dann ging es darum, dass man halt die Waffenlieferung und die Befähigung der
Ukraine deutlich antreibt,
um einfach den Druck, den militärischen Druck auf Russland zu erhöhen,
was möglich ist, was auch die aktuelle Situation sehr wohl zeigt.
Weil die Russen, ich würde nicht sagen, sie pfeifen aus dem letzten Loch,
aber sie kämpfen auf jeden Fall nicht mit einer unbeschränkten Menge an Ressourcen,
sondern es zeigt sich schon,
dass in dem Moment, wo die Russen unter Druck gesetzt werden,
sie Schwierigkeiten haben, diese Lücken auch zu füllen.
Ihr ganzer Materialpark geht einfach Schritt für Schritt zur Neige und wenn
man ihnen keine Gelegenheit gibt, den wieder aufzubauen,
naja, dann stehen sie halt irgendwann dann auch ohne militärische Mittel da,
zumindest in bestimmten Bereichen wie Fahrzeugen, nicht so sehr Raketen und
so, aber ohne Fahrzeuge wird es dann schon schwierig, eine Landinvasion durchzuführen.
Dann sieht dieser Siegesplan vor, so eine Art NATO-Truppenstationierung durchzuführen.
Das ist sozusagen die Idee, dass man eben NATO-Staaten dazu bringt,
mit eigenen Truppen in der Ukraine präsent zu sein, zum Beispiel in Gebieten,
in denen jetzt nicht aktiv gekämpft wird.
Sagen wir mal so im Norden, die Grenze zu Weißrussland oder halt auch im Westen,
wäre es ja durchaus vorstellbar, dass dort...
NATO-Staaten-Kampfverbände stationieren, um dort eben für die Sicherheit zu sorgen.
Weil überall, wo die quasi aushelfen, muss die Ukraine keine eigenen Ressourcen
aufbringen und kann sich eben voll auf den Kampf an der Front konzentrieren.
Ja, bloß bei der Logistik zu helfen, kann man sich auch gut vorstellen.
Genau. Also das kann nur hilfreich sein.
Punkt Nielsen hatte dann diesen schönen Begriff der Tripwire Force,
das ist natürlich dann sozusagen auch so ein Stolperdraht für die Russen,
weil das sind dann auch so Gebiete, die wollen sie dann auch nicht angreifen,
weil wenn sie dann sozusagen NATO-Truppen direkt beschießen,
dann löst es halt unter Umständen wiederum eine andere Reaktion aus.
Und dann soll natürlich die ukrainische Wirtschaft gestützt werden,
die an sich dafür, dass sie so lange im Krieg sind,
relativ gut läuft aber natürlich noch sehr viel mehr Unterstützung braucht ja
und generell muss halt irgendwie diese westliche Allianz gestärkt werden,
aber das Thema haben wir natürlich ohnehin, aber,
wie schon gesagt diesen Siegesplan, den ja,
haben sich alle schön gefreut, dass den vorgestellt hat, aber so richtig zu
äußern wollte sich eigentlich keiner, weil US-Wahl. Und wir wissen ja nicht.
Ja.
Ja, und jetzt war US-Wahl.
Und gestern saßen wir noch so zusammen und haben uns unsere Gedanken gemacht.
Was ist denn dein Gedanke, Pavel?
Ja, ich hatte jetzt nicht vermutet, dass Trump so deutlich gewinnen wird.
Das war ja doch etwas eine Überraschung.
Aber auf der anderen Seite erspart das jetzt so ein ewiges Gezerre und Chaos,
was halt auch hätte eintreten können, dass man jetzt irgendwie wochenlang nicht weiß, was los ist.
Insofern, das ist vielleicht das Gute daran,
dass das jetzt einfach mal für Klarheit gesorgt hat,
was der amerikanische Wähler so mehrheitlich dann möchte und das scheint offenbar Trump zu sein.
Ja, also wir nehmen jetzt diese Sendung hier 20 Uhr am 6.
November auf. Seit ein paar Stunden ist es halt dann auch wirklich total klar,
dass diese Wahl an Trump gegangen ist.
Und ich habe mal einen kurzen Blick auf die...
Auf die Gesamtwahlergebnisse, also wie viele haben jetzt eigentlich für Trump
gestimmt und wie viele haben für Harris gestimmt.
Und dann ist es tatsächlich so, dass Trump, glaube ich, drei Millionen Stimmen
weniger bekommen hat als beim letzten Mal.
Aber Harris hat halt noch sehr viel mehr verloren. Das heißt,
sie waren nicht in der Lage, das Wählerpotenzial zu mobilisieren,
was Biden vor vier Jahren mobilisiert hat.
Und das ist eigentlich, sagen wir mal, das, was mich am meisten überrascht.
Also dass jetzt Trump irgendwie gewinnt durch dieses bekloppte Wahlmänner-System,
dass quasi so gewinnst du einen Staat, gewinnst du alle Stimmen und so weiter.
Also das hätte ich mir auch noch irgendwie vorstellen können.
Aber dass sie jetzt tatsächlich auch die Popular Vote verlieren,
die Demokraten, das muss ich sagen, ist vor allem das Beunruhigende.
Außerdem ist es noch beunruhigend, dass sie auch noch den Senat und vielleicht
auch noch das Haus verloren haben.
Also wenn sie sozusagen jetzt auch, wenn sie ihnen noch nicht mal gelingt,
die Mehrheit im Haus zurückzugewinnen, dann ist halt nicht nur Trump der Präsident,
sondern das ist halt einfach die Republikaner ohne irgendwelche Grenzen.
Und das ist eigentlich das Schlimmste dann von allem.
Ja, im Moment zumindest sah es noch so aus, dass die Demokraten aber das Haus gewinnen könnten,
aber steht noch nicht endgültig fest, glaube ich.
Ja gut, das werden wir dann sehen. Aber am Ende wissen wir eben,
wie viel auch mit einem republikanischen Haus, der Biden als Präsident hat, machen können.
Gut, da hat ihm natürlich auch geholfen, dass sie im Senat eine knappe Mehrheit
hatten, aber ich mache mir da nicht so viel Illusion.
Und wir wissen ja auch, wie destruktiv die Politik von Trump sein wird,
dass alle Mittel und Wege finden werden, allem was sinnvoll ist,
da Stöcker zwischen die Beine zu werfen.
Ja, jetzt ist natürlich die große Frage, die sich alle stellen,
was wird passieren, was wird Trump tun,
wie schlimm wird es denn eigentlich werden.
Und ja, mein ein Merkmal von Trump ist eine gewisse Unberechenbarkeit.
Ich glaube, er weiß selber nicht, was er irgendwie am nächsten Tag so tun wird.
Und er ist da eben durchaus impulsiv.
Allerdings gibt es auch eine gewisse Kontinuität oder gewisse Grundeigenschaften,
von denen man annehmen kann.
Die ihn leiten werden.
Das eine ist seine Transaktionalität.
Das heißt, er sieht in allem irgendwie einen Deal,
wo man irgendwie Profit machen kann und muss und soll.
Und das zusammen mit America First lässt er ahnen, wie seine Außenpolitik aussehen wird.
Dass er nämlich gucken wird, was kann er rausholen.
Sowohl was die Verbündeten angeht, mit denen er, glaube ich,
gewisse persönliche Probleme hat. weil die ihn alle nicht so unbedingt mögen und respektieren.
Und da hat er, glaube ich, auch gewisse Minderwertigkeitskomplexe.
Aber am Ende kennt Trump eigentlich keine Freunde.
Das heißt auch, wenn er jetzt,
was jetzt Putin angeht oder was jetzt Xi angeht,
Und am Ende des Tages wird er auch denen gegenüber sich transaktional verhalten.
Das heißt, eben gucken...
Ja, was springt für Amerika dabei raus?
Und dann kommt noch dazu, dass er
ja bisher auch schon Anleihen aus dem faschistischen Playbook gemacht hat.
Und da ist eben auch zu erwarten, dass er jetzt Amerika umkrempeln möchte,
auch auf eine Art und Weise,
dass zukünftig die Demokraten nicht mehr an die Macht kommen.
Also quasi so ein bisschen à la Orban, sich die zukünftige Macht dann auch noch zu sichern.
Das bleibt abzuwarten, wie gut das in den USA funktionieren wird.
Allein schon deshalb, weil die Bundesstaaten halt doch eine gewisse Autonomie
haben und sich jetzt auch vom Bund nicht überall reinregieren lassen.
Also Kalifornien wird jetzt da nicht, oder andere demokratisch regierte Länder
werden da gewissen Widerstand leisten.
Davon kann man ausgehen, dass er jetzt da nicht einfach einen Durchmarsch haben wird.
Und was jetzt konkret die Ukraine betrifft, gibt es auch einen Plan,
der ist in diesem berühmten Project 2025 eben auch mit formuliert,
was Trump, wie er sich das vorstellt, wenn er drankommt, hat er ja gesagt,
wird er den Krieg jetzt in einem Tag beenden.
Und der Plan sieht halt vor,
dass ja die Ukraine und Russland zu einem sofortigen Waffenstillstand auffordern
wird und verlangen, dass sich unter anderem irgendwie beide Seiten von der Front zurückziehen.
Und dann sollte jetzt Russland nicht zu einem Waffenstillstand bereit sein,
würde er dann der Ukraine mehr Waffen geben, um Russland zu bestrafen.
Und sollte die Ukraine nicht bereit sein, Waffenstillstand zu machen,
würde er der Ukraine die Unterstützung entziehen.
Also so stellt er sich das vor oder so stellen sich seine Leute das vor,
dass man mit diesem Konflikt beenden könnte.
Ich meine das natürlich ein bisschen, wir sollten gleich vielleicht mal reinkommentieren,
also dass die Ukraine sich zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt und vor allem zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt oder auch dem Zeitpunkt dann im Januar auf den Waffenstillstand einlässt,
das ist so zu 100% ausgeschlossen.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendein Druckmittel gibt,
was die Ukraine davon abhalten wird, sich weiter zu verteidigen und jede Gelegenheit
zu nutzen, die Russen weiter davon zu jagen.
Das wird also nicht passieren.
Oder siehst du irgendein Druckmittel, das die USA ausüben kann?
Was dazu führen könnte?
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht. Allerdings, sag ich mal, erst mal bei diesem Plan,
ich meine, Russland wird dringend eine Kampfpause brauchen.
Die verausgaben sich im Moment dermaßen, dass sie einfach zurückfahren müssen
und werden dann sicherlich versuchen,
das Ganze zu verkaufen als freundschaftliche Geste,
dass sie an Trump, dass sie ja jetzt willens und bereit sind.
Ja, aber das alleine wird halt schwierig sein, so einen Waffenstillstand zu organisieren.
Das wird sicherlich nicht innerhalb von 24 Stunden passieren.
Ja, also so schnell lässt sich das alleine nicht mal organisieren,
selbst wenn sich die Seiten darauf einigen würden aus irgendwelchen Gründen
und ich kann es mir tatsächlich jetzt auch nicht vorstellen.
Plus, wir haben ja 2014 auch gesehen, als so mit großem Druck aus dem Westen
der Waffenstillstand ausgehandelt wurde,
dass der eben auch lange Zeit, also über Jahre weg erstmal brüchig war und dass das,
ich weiß nicht, fünf, sechs Jahre gedauert hat, bis dann tatsächlich die Kampfhandlungen
nachgelassen haben allmählich.
Bis dann die Russen dann komplett mit 200.000 Leuten einmarschiert sind.
Und so, also, ja, deswegen, also wird schwierig auf der anderen Seite,
wenn die USA Druck macht,
wird die Ukraine schon sich auch Verhandlungen nicht entziehen können.
Und gehen wir mal davon aus, dass man.
Ja, wenn es zu Verhandlungen kommt und früher oder später wird es zu Verhandlungen kommen,
dann wird Russland wahrscheinlich erstmal mit seinen bisherigen komplett absurden
Forderungen ins Rennen gehen, die wir ja auch immer vernommen haben,
die natürlich völlig inakzeptabel sein werden für die Russen.
Aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass Trumps Position sein wird,
dass er akzeptieren wird, dass Russland den Großteil des besetzten Landes auch erstmal besetzt hält.
Also er wird da nicht die Ukraine dahingehend stützen, dass die Russen da jetzt
komplett raus müssen oder so.
Das ist zu befürchten, das hat er gesagt.
Aber es ist auch nicht davon auszugehen, dass in den nächsten Jahrzehnten, egal was passiert.
Die Welt oder die Ukraine anerkennen wird oder irgendwelches Land an Russland abtreten wird.
Also selbst wenn Russland das besetzt hält,
wird es nicht zu einer Lösung kommen, dass das halt anerkannt wird.
So, dann wird Trump durchaus wahrscheinlich bereit sein, auch gewisse Sanktionen
aufzuheben und da ist aber völlig unklar,
dass irgendeine Wirkung haben wird oder welche Wirkung das haben wird und ob
er überhaupt dazu bereit sein wird. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst.
Also das ist eigentlich ein...
Das ist eigentlich so der Punkt, der mir jetzt kurzfristig am meisten Sorgen macht.
Weil die Sanktionen, die bisher da sind, klar, die werden immer schnell behauptet,
das hätte ja alles nichts gebracht, das stimmt nicht. Also diese Sanktionen
setzen Russland schon extrem unter Druck.
Wenn man sich allein anschaut, wie es jetzt zuletzt finanziell in Russland so
abgeht und wir haben ja glaube ich in der letzten Sendung auch schon relativ
ausführlich über diesen ganzen Punkt gesprochen, welche Implikationen das hat,
dass da so viel Geld ins Militär gesteckt wird, dass das sozusagen die Inflation
hochdrückt, Butterpreise steigen etc.
Tun sie mittlerweile bei uns auch, aber aus anderen Gründen.
Aber das ist, sagen wir mal, das soziale Desaster, das nimmt Formen an und es
ist nicht absehbar, dass es groß nachlässt.
Und diese Sanktionen verhindern zwar nicht, aber machen es Russland auf jeden
Fall sehr schwer und für Russland auch sehr teuer, an die ganzen Dinge ranzukommen,
die sie unbedingt brauchen für gerade ihre Hightech-Produktion.
Also klar, Panzer kriegen die immer noch zusammengeschweißt,
das ist nicht so das Problem.
Öl haben die eh genug, aber wenn es dann halt um Elektronik geht,
um Raw Materials, die sie dann vielleicht nicht haben etc.
Pp., da sind diese Sanktionen schon wirksam. Auch vor allem jetzt die von beiden
zuletzt in zunehmendem Maße hochgedrehten sekundären Sanktionen.
Also dass quasi jetzt Firmen oder Banken zum Beispiel in China oder in Indien
bestraft werden oder größere Unternehmen bestraft werden und aus dem US-Handel
rausgenommen werden, wenn klar wird, dass die halt hintenrum in irgendeiner
Form an Russland liefern.
Und wenn diese sekundären Sanktionen aufgehoben werden oder nicht weiter angezogen
werden, dann wird das schon erheblich dazu beitragen, dass Russland eben seine
Kampffähigkeit wieder erhöhen kann.
Ja, allerdings sagen wir, wenn man davon ausgeht, wie gesagt,
von Trumps Transaktionalität und seiner Sicht,
dass China der eigentliche Gegner ist.
Dann würde wahrscheinlich die USA gar nicht so sehr profitieren von der Aufhebung der Sanktionen.
Das ist sozusagen der andere Punkt. Also wenn man das durch die Brille sieht,
was hat dann Amerika davon?
Ist das jetzt erstmal nicht, also könnte es sein,
dass sie zu der Erkenntnis kommen, dass Amerika nichts davon hat und dass das
eher den Chinesen und anderen Ländern dann mehr Vorteile bereiten würde.
Und solange dann nicht Russland irgendwie bezahlt für die Aufhebung der Sanktionen.
Das glaube ich auch erstmal nicht passieren, aber grundsätzlich ist vorstellbar,
dass Trump tatsächlich dort Sanktionen aufheben wird.
Was ich aber auch für unwahrscheinlich halte,
ist, dass man sich auf irgendeine Form von Demilitarisierung einigen wird.
So nach dem Motto, ja, alle Truppen müssen jetzt nicht 30 oder 50 Kilometer
von der Frontlinie entfernt weggezogen werden.
Oder was Russland ja auch fordert,
ist, dass die Ukraine maximal 50.000 Soldaten haben soll in Zukunft.
Also das war auch so eine Idee, das Rüstungskontrolle.
Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo sich die USA aus diesem Konflikt zurückzieht und
nicht mehr bereit ist, Unterstützung zu leisten,
und das bliebe ja erstmal abzuwarten, also kündigt er jetzt sozusagen jede Unterstützung auf,
gibt es gar keine Waffenlieferungen mehr, Was kann die beiden Administrationen
jetzt noch durch langfristige Verpflichtungen bis zum Januar sicherstellen,
dass das noch weiter läuft oder bricht es sozusagen sofort ein und dann nimmt
sich natürlich die USA auch aus dem politischen Spiel.
Weil ich meine, wenn sie die Ukraine eh nicht mehr unterstützen und es alles
bei Europa hängt, ja was ist denn dann noch?
Also ich meine, warum soll denn die Ukraine auf die USA hören und warum soll
sie denn auf Trump hören?
Und damit nimmt er sich natürlich dann auch selber aus dem Spiel.
Ob ihm das recht ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe auch immer so den Eindruck,
es geht ihm nicht darum, dass für Amerika irgendwas drin ist,
sondern es geht ihm eigentlich nur darum, dass irgendwas für ihn dabei ist.
Ja, naja, für ihn dabei ist halt, dass er sich dann damit brüsten kann,
einen tollen Deal gemacht zu haben, wie viel er dann rausgeschlagen hat.
Also das ist sozusagen für ihn drin. Ich meine, er ist auch ein Populist und
möchte dann gerne schon auch irgendwo sich mit irgendwas...
Aber es hat ihn doch jetzt bisher nicht davon abgehalten. Ich meine,
er brüstet sich doch am laufenden Meter mit Dingen, die er nicht getan hat.
Also ich meine, im Zweifelsfall empfindet er halt einfach irgendetwas.
Da müssen ja gar keine tatsächlichen, wirklichen Dinge stattfinden.
Ja, das ist natürlich die andere Sache oder das andere Grundproblem.
Aber...
Ich sag mal, klar, zu Hause kann er halt eine ganze Menge erzählen und manche
Leute glauben ihm dann auch.
Aber so seine Glaubwürdigkeit ist eigentlich auch nicht sehr hoch.
Also selbst die Leute, die ihn gewählt haben, glauben ihm oder viele davon glauben
ihm einfach nichts von dem, was er sagt.
Also es ist nicht so, dass er jetzt glaubwürdig ist, aber ja,
es ist halt, auf jeden Fall hat man ja jetzt auch gesehen,
dass dort auch in der Bewegung halt so sektenähnliche Zustände herrschen und
dass da auch teilweise der absolute Irrsinn regiert.
Und man wird halt sehen,
aber mit diesem Irrsinn kommt man halt auf dem internationalen Paket dann nur begrenzt weit.
Ja, das ist so die andere Sache, weil klar kann er behaupten,
es ist jetzt Frieden in der Ukraine,
aber wenn dort weitergekämpft wird.
Ganz so funktioniert das dann halt nicht.
Und vor allen Dingen akzeptieren die Leute im Wahlkampf so andere Dinge,
gehen davon aus, dass sowieso alle nur Quatsch erzählen.
Aber ganz so leicht wird es mit dem Lügen auf Dauer oder in der Intensität mit
dem Wahnsinn jetzt, glaube ich, nicht weitergehen und nicht funktionieren,
weil dann kriegst du halt auch nichts erledigt.
Das ist das Problem.
Und es sorgt dann doch für zu viel Friktion.
Und was natürlich jetzt,
Aber interessant sein wird und wo mir auch wirklich schwerfällt,
das vorherzusagen ist, wie Europa und Deutschland jetzt reagieren werden.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal sagen, was wir denken, wie Europa reagieren sollte
und dann schauen wir mal darauf, wie sie wahrscheinlich darauf reagieren werden.
Okay, also was ich machen würde, wenn ich jetzt Europa wäre und irgendwie mit Trump umgehen sollte,
würde ich ihm halt einen Deal vorschlagen.
So gute, altbewährte deutsche Scheckbuchpolitik, wie wir das genannt haben,
damals würden sagen, okay, hier ist der Deal, Trump.
Die Ukraine braucht halt weiter Waffen.
Ihr habt Waffen und produziert auch jede Menge davon.
Und du bist doch bestimmt froh darüber,
wenn wir euch einen Haufen Waffen abkaufen, das erhält amerikanische Arbeitsplätze,
das steigert euer Bruttosozialprodukt.
Und so, ja, wir finanzieren das Ganze jetzt und sorgen dafür,
dass bei euch die Kasse klingelt und du stell dich nicht so an mit den Waffen,
was willst du denn sonst machen.
Wir brauchen sowieso erstmal nur die alten, die ihr sowieso wegschmeißen wolltet.
Wir kaufen, ihr braucht euch dann neue.
Ja, also das wäre wie ich als Europa versuchen würde, einfach Trump mit seiner,
Transaktionalität zu kriegen.
Das war teuer.
Ja. Aber ja,
Ich meine,
wird aber möglicherweise nötig, um dann die Zeit zu überbrücken,
bis man dann in Europa vielleicht auch aufholt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, die USA sind nun mal,
was so Technologie und Forschung und militärisch-industrieller Komplex und so angeht,
reicht da einfach kein Land.
Der Erde auch nur annähernd heran.
Ja, das ist einfach, ich meine, die geben genauso viel Geld aus,
die Amerikaner, wie der ganze Rest der Welt für Rüstung.
Und das jetzt schon einfach seit Jahrzehnten.
Und haben halt immer noch, ich meine, obwohl es jetzt runtergeschrumpft ist,
Aber Amerikaner betreiben 500 Militärstützpunkte weltweit.
Und die haben einfach Mengen an Militär und pumpen da Mengen an Geld rein.
Wie gesagt, da musst du die Rüstungsausgaben vom Rest der Welt zusammennehmen,
um dem etwas entgegensetzen zu können.
Und Europa wahrscheinlich, weiß nicht, Mit etwas mehr Einwohnern ja vielleicht
ein Drittel gefühlt von dem, was die USA ausgibt.
Und mit auch wesentlich höheren Ineffektivitäten.
Das Problem ist, um dort die USA annähernd zu ersetzen,
das dürfte Jahrzehnte dauern.
Es sei denn, wir werden direkt in den Krieg verwickelt und fahren dann innerhalb
von drei oder vier Jahren fährt Europa massiv die Rüstungsproduktion hoch.
Das könnte halt auch passieren.
Also ich meine, wir sind ja in einen Krieg verwickelt.
Und ich glaube, es muss jetzt erstmal der Groschen fallen in Europa, dass das so ist.
Ich meine, wir werden jetzt erfolgreich von den Wagenknechts und sonstigen Stiefelknechten
Russlands dahin gezogen, immer zu glauben,
das würde uns alles nichts angehen.
Aber die Realität ist...
Russland sagt mehr oder weniger klar, also man muss ja nur russisches Fernsehen
einschalten und den Sprechern des Kremls zuhören, die erzählen einfach in die
Kamera rein, dass sie irgendwie ihr altes Imperium wieder haben wollen.
Und wenn man mal so ein bisschen zurückspult so in der Geschichte,
das war ganz schön groß. Ja.
Und das ist das schon mal so ganz Osteuropa so und da gehören die baltischen
Staaten dazu und Finnland und natürlich auch Polen und das ist halt einfach deren Ziel.
So, irgendwie glauben wir noch, naja die nagen sich da ein bisschen was von
der Ukraine ab und dann werden sie schon Ruhe geben und dann weißt du, diese,
Vorstellung, man müsste ja nur so einen Teil der Ukraine wegopfern und dann
bleibt da so ein Rest und dann ist wieder Ruhe und dann können wir wieder in
Ruhe RTL Plus gucken so wird es halt nicht funktionieren,
weil die Russen werden jede Kampfpause nutzen weiterhin mit ihrer aufgedrehten
Militärmaschine dann vielleicht von Sanktionen auch befreit.
Diesen Militärapparat wieder aufzubauen innerhalb von zehn Jahren und dann geht
es halt irgendwann den nächsten Schritt und das ist irgendwie das,
was glaube ich hier immer noch keiner so richtig verstanden hat,
dass dieses Land aktiv daran arbeitet, sich irgendwie Land in Europa wieder zurückzuholen.
Wir sind mittlerweile so dermaßen pazifiziert, glaube ich, in unserem Gedanken,
dass wir uns das noch nicht mal mehr vorstellen können, selbst wenn es unmittelbar
direkt vor unserer Nase passiert.
Ja, ich meine, es ist schön, wie man amerikanischen Wählern immer vorwerfen
kann, so ja, ihr seht ja nicht,
schaut doch einfach mal hin, wie der Trump so ist, das passiert ja alles vor euren Augen,
aber genauso ist ja hier die Realitätsverweigerung auch so ausgeprägt,
dass man eben auch nicht bereit ist, das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen,
was dort passiert und irgendwie glaubt, man könnte das so wegignorieren.
Ja, naja, die Überlegung ist, naja, man macht halt, also die Russen werden schon nicht kommen.
Also wenn sie schon solche Probleme mit der Ukraine hatten, ja,
werden sie jetzt nicht weiter irgendwie versuchen, sich mit der NATO anzulegen.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Denke, glaube ich.
Und ganz ehrlich gesagt weiß natürlich niemand,
was passieren wird, aber es ist natürlich auch ein klares Muster erkennbar,
so was Russland angeht, nämlich Tschetschenien, damit ging das halt los.
Aber da kann man sagen, na gut, das war völkerrechtlich Teil von Russland.
Aber dann natürlich Moldawien, wo sie mal eben ein Stück abgezwackt haben und
bis heute besetzt halten.
Georgien war dann das zweite Ding und dann kam natürlich die Ukraine.
Also das Muster ist natürlich schon auf jeden Fall da.
Und bei Weißrussland warten sie eigentlich nur darauf, dass der Lukaschenko
irgendwie den Löffel abgibt, um sich das endgültig einzuverleiben.
Also das läuft ja dann eher so schleichend und dann glaube ich, wenn das gelingt.
Sich halt auch noch andere Ecken der ehemaligen Sowjetunion dann natürlich versuchen da anzueignen.
Aber ob sie dann tatsächlich irgendwann in drei, vier, fünf Jahren die Kraft
und Entschlossenheit haben werden,
sich mit der NATO anzulegen, eher fraglich.
Also, ich bin auch nicht bereit zu akzeptieren,
das jetzt nur auf dem Prinzip der Landnahme zu diskutieren, sondern...
Russland mischt sich in unsere Wahlen mit ein. Russland mischt sich in die amerikanische Wahl mit ein.
Russland ist hinter der Brexit-Entscheidung gewesen.
Russland schnappt sich irgendwie vielleicht noch Georgien ganz,
ja, also die Wahlen, die da jetzt gelaufen sind.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch das mitbekommen hat, aber da waren jetzt gerade
Parlamentswahlen, wo einfach massiv Wahlbetrug vorgelegen hat und nur dadurch
der aktuelle Präsident, der halt irgendwie von Russen gekauft wurde,
irgendwie an der Macht bleibt.
Und die jetzt in zunehmendem Maße wieder an der Politik betreiben,
die sie von der EU wegbringen, wo sie eigentlich beitreten wollten.
Und zwei Teile des Landes sind sowieso schon akut russisch besetzt,
also Südostetien und Abkhazien.
Und wenn sie sich eben dann die ganze, ganz Georgien reinholen,
dann wird es auch nicht mehr so lange dauern, bis irgendwie Armenien dann angedockt wird.
Also das nimmt halt weiter zu und führt einfach dazu, dass einfach Russland
so seine invasive Art da einfach weiter pflegt.
Weil das ist einfach im Prinzip das letzte Kolonialimperium,
was wir auf diesem Planeten noch haben und was halt also wirklich in akuter
Landnahme und auch eben mit dieser inhaltlichen Inversion in andere Länder versucht,
dem Rest der Welt seine Agenda aufzudrängen.
Und das wird auch weiterhin für Probleme sorgen.
Das wird für wirtschaftliche Probleme sorgen und es wird auch weiterhin für
politische Probleme sorgen.
Und auch das ist eben Teil dieser Kriegsführung.
Und Cyberkrieg fange ich jetzt gar nicht erst mit an, findet sowieso auf täglicher Beweis statt.
Also wir sehen ja, was es irgendwie aus den USA gemacht hat alles.
Also das muss schon irgendwie zurückgedrängt werden und man muss halt jetzt
mal aufhören, dieses Appeasement zu betreiben, weil so hat er sich die Krim geholt,
so ist auch diese Inversion jetzt in der Ukraine gelaufen und wenn die EU als
Friedensprojekt noch irgendeine Bedeutung haben will,
Langfristig auch wirtschaftlich muss dem einfach ein Riegel vorgeschoben werden.
Ja, ich meine, letztlich, was zum Ukraine-Krieg geführt hat,
war ein Versagen von Abschreckung.
Ja, das ist so der Punkt. Das heißt,
wir werden so oder so, also wenn wir Frieden bewahren wollen,
bleibt nichts anderes als Abschreckung.
Die billigste Form der Abschreckung wäre natürlich,
wenn man der Ukraine das Nötigste zur Verfügung stellt, um den Krieg zu gewinnen.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach die beste Variante.
Aber ja, ansonsten,
wenn Russland jetzt quasi belohnt wird für seinen Aggressionskrieg in irgendeiner Form,
dann wird das halt weitere Konflikte nach sich ziehen.
Also wahrscheinlicher machen.
Und um dann Abschreckung zu betreiben, indem wir selbst aufrüsten.
Ich meine, Polen geht ja ganz klar diesen Weg.
Also die Polen sehen das so, dass die jetzt dabei sind, ja die größte,
stärkste Armee in Westeuropa aufzubauen.
Ich meine, die haben allein 500 Heimars geordert. und mittlerweile fast 2000
Kampfpanzer oder so, die sie sich zulegen wollen.
Also Polen macht da ernst und da wird dann Europa wahrscheinlich oder der Rest
von Europa einfach mitziehen müssen.
Und das ist natürlich insbesondere deshalb tragisch, dass wir einfach dann jetzt
Gewaltige über die nächsten 10, 15 Jahre dann gewaltig aufrüsten müssen.
Und das wird natürlich zu Lasten vieler anderen Dinge gehen wie Bildung,
Gesundheit, Sozialunterstützung.
Und ja, ja.
Also wir laufen da jetzt definitiv in Probleme rein.
Und das geht jetzt noch davon aus, dass die Instabilitäten, die durch Trump jetzt entstehen,
nicht auch noch die Welt in eine Weltwirtschaftskrise stürzen oder in eine Rezession.
Und dann gibt es ja noch andere Schauplätze.
Und wie gesagt, China guckt halt auch genau zu, was dort passiert. Das ist das andere Ding.
Und wenn sich jetzt rausstellt oder wenn die Chinesen den Eindruck bekommen,
ja, Amerika lässt seine Verbündeten hängen, dann werden die sich ermuntert fühlen.
Ja, Taiwan dann halt eventuell zu versuchen einzusacken militärisch.
Ja, lass uns nicht zu weit abtreiben. Also ich denke, es wäre jetzt sehr wichtig,
aber ich bin da ehrlich gesagt skeptisch, es wäre jetzt sehr wichtig,
dass die EU zusammenrückt.
Aber dadurch, dass die EU es noch nicht mal geschafft hat, irgendwie so einen
Stinker wie Orban klein zu halten, mache ich mir ehrlich gesagt gerade sehr
wenig Hoffnung, dass hier irgendwas Nennenswertes passieren wird.
Also es ist einfach die aktuelle Struktur der EU lässt es einfach nicht zu,
hier wirklich voranzukommen und so ungern ich das sage,
könnte es eben dann doch mal wieder auf so eine Art innere Spaltung hinauslaufen.
Im Idealfall mit sozusagen so einer Art.
Externen europäischen,
Vereinigungen von Ländern, so Coalition of the Willing, die unabhängig von der
EU anfangen Dinge zu beschließen.
Was vielleicht zum Beispiel auch Großbritannien mit reinnehmen könnte.
Und wenn Frankreich, gut Deutschland müsste natürlich auch dabei sein,
Mal gucken, was das politisch bei uns alles noch bedeuten wird,
aber das lassen wir jetzt mal raus.
Aber wenn, sagen wir mal, so diese Kernmächte Europas sagen einfach,
wir wollen uns jetzt hier nicht von Orbán aufhalten lassen, was wir in der EU
nicht beschließen können, das machen wir einfach bilateral unter uns aus.
Und wir organisieren jetzt hier eine entsprechende Maßnahme,
um militärisch stark zu sein, eine Abschreckung an den Start zu bringen und
auch die entsprechende Unterstützung zu liefern.
Teilweise ist das ja auch schon jetzt bei diesen ganzen EU-Deals ähnlich angedroht
worden und wir hatten auch gesehen, dass man Orban so ein bisschen in die Ecke
kriegt, aber der wird sich natürlich jetzt bestärkt fühlen und das sieht so für die EU nicht gut aus.
Ich meine, viel wird auch davon abhängen, wie denn Trump mit seinem Projekt
Machtergreifung vorankommen wird.
Weil da gibt es, glaube ich, in Europa einfach eine andere, sensiblere Sicht drauf.
Und wenn jetzt Trump dort anfängt, tatsächlich politische Gegner zu verfolgen, mithilfe der Justiz,
mithilfe von Staatsanwälten und mithilfe von Steuerbehörden und mithilfe von...
Gibt es einen Schoenkorb?
Immer, ja, ja. Und dort halt, was weiß ich, dann irgendwelchen Sendern Lizenzen
entziehen wird oder, ja,
also das wird man schon sehr, sehr genau beobachten.
Und das könnte natürlich auch zu erheblichen Spannungen und Konflikten zwischen
Europa und den USA führen und sozusagen die Bereitschaft,
dann auch, ja,
Einerseits sich mit Trump zu arrangieren oder ihm Paroli zu bieten,
wird eben auch sehr stark davon abhängen, wie er sich verhält,
was so Menschenrechte angeht.
Und das kann halt auch ziemlich übel werden.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch nicht so einfach, gerade in den USA.
Darauf hoffen zumindest viele. Aber es sind natürlich jetzt,
also wo auch alle von ausgehen, ist, dass es jetzt ganz anders sein wird als,
2016, wo er da eher unvorbereitet war, beziehungsweise dann der Rest von MAGA
unvorbereitet haben, gibt es jetzt zumindest Pläne.
Genau. Wechseln wir doch mal genau auf diesen innenpolitischen Aspekt. Also,
was könnte da jetzt passieren.
Unabhängig von Ja, also was in den USA passieren wird, ist, dass definitiv die
Qualität des Personals in der Bundesregierung abnehmen wird.
Das kann man, also wenn dort, also Trump hatte ja bereits in der ersten Regierungsperiode
einen ziemlich hohen Verschleiß an hochrangigen Mitarbeitern.
Und mittlerweile muss er da ziemlich tief in die Tonne greifen,
um da Leute rauszuholen.
Und die Leute zeichnen sich dann vor allem durch Loyalität aus und nicht unbedingt durch Sachverstand.
Und das führt dann im Gegenzug dazu auch dadurch, dass er jetzt wieder einführen wird,
dass viele Bundesbedienstete nur noch at will beschäftigt werden.
Er halt im Prinzip jeden feuern kann, der ihm nicht passt in den Behörden.
Also er möchte da dann schon.
Gerne durchregieren und das wird nicht unbedingt zu einer Verbesserung der Personalqualität
führen, sondern eher umgekehrt.
Dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass es wieder mehr Unruhen gibt.
Ich meine, das war ja während Trumps Zeit irgendwie Black Lives Matter und so
weiter. Es war ja relativ ruhig unter beiden in den USA, was so Rassenunruhen und so weiter angeht.
Aber da kann man fest davon ausgehen, dass es wieder mehr Unruhen geben wird,
mehr Protesten gegen alles Mögliche.
Dann ist davon auszugehen, dass die Kriminalitätsrate wieder ansteigen wird in den USA.
Einfach aufgrund dessen, dass Sozialleistungen gestrichen werden und der Konkurrenzdruck
oder der wirtschaftliche Druck in der Gesellschaft zunehmen wird.
Vor allen Dingen für den unteren Teil der Gesellschaft und der deutlichste Zusammenhang
zwischen Kriminalitätsrate und irgendetwas Politischem ist halt Wohlstand.
Also je besser es den Leuten geht, so insgesamt umso weniger kriminell sind sie so.
Überraschung, aber ja, so ist das halt. Also zumindest bei sehr,
sehr vielen Eigentumsdelikten, so Raub und andere Dinge.
Wenn die Leute nichts zu verlieren haben, dann werden sie halt eher kriminell.
Das ist eigentlich fast ein No-Brainer und die Wissenschaft bestätigt das auch.
Man kann mit Sicherheit davon ausgehen, dass Trump eben auch auf Widerstand
gegen seine Politik treffen wird, auf allen möglichen Ebenen.
Also die 48 Prozent, die Harris gewählt haben, werden jetzt nicht sagen, naja, okay,
dann lassen wir mal jetzt sagen, das ist uns jetzt egal, wir akzeptieren das jetzt einfach.
Sondern ja, da wird es Widerstand geben auf allen möglichen Ebenen und ja,
bestimmte Bundesbehörden werden natürlich ja potenziell chaotische Verhältnisse auftreten.
Also ich meine, wo sich einem schon ein bisschen,
wo sich mir zumindest jetzt ein bisschen auch der Magen umdreht,
ist, was jetzt Elon Musk angeht oder auch Kennedy.
Also Kennedy als Gesundheitsminister, der ja zum einen ein bekannter Impfgegner ist,
Fluoridisierung des Trinkwassers sofort beenden wird, weil er glaubt,
das Fluor im Trinkwasser für, ja, keine Ahnung, was...
Hat er im Internet gelesen, muss stimmen.
Ja, genau. Aber auf der anderen Seite, und das ist wiederum dann,
Ich meine, die amerikanischen Lebensmittel sind deutlich ungesünder als europäische Lebensmittel.
Da herrscht einfach eine etwas andere Philosophie.
Und da ist es eher so im Zweifelsfall für den Produzenten,
während in der EU eher die Philosophie im Zweifelsfall für den Konsumenten ist.
Und es gibt halt eine große Grauzone an Dingen, wo man nicht hundertprozentig weiß,
ob sie jetzt schädlich sind, aber wo es gute Gründe dafür gibt und die halt in der EU verboten sind.
Aber es gibt auch sehr viele, ja, also wenn man sich allein nur Beispiel Heinz Ketchup anguckt,
man würde jetzt denken, okay, Heinz Ketchup, das ist so ein Markenprodukt,
das ist wahrscheinlich weltweit einheitlich.
Ja, aber nein, in Europa besteht eben Heinz-Ketchup im Wesentlichen aus,
weiß nicht, Tomaten, Zucker und Essig.
So, da sind irgendwie drei oder vier Zutaten drin.
So, im amerikanischen Heinz-Ketchup hast du dann zusätzlich,
ja, noch andere Mittel, die noch nicht mal vollständig aufgeführt sind.
Unter anderem Aromastoffe drin und ja und so sieht das halt überall aus oder
wenn du dir anguckst in amerikanischem Weißbrot ist die vierfache Menge an Zucker drin,
wie in deutschem Weißbrot zum Beispiel und könntest jetzt ja Ich will darauf
hinaus dass dann tatsächlich selbst in diesem Gesamtdesaster.
Im Sinne von in der Politik,
gibt es ja immer wieder, also kommt es anders, als man denkt.
Oder da wird ein Gesetz erlassen und dann passieren aber ganz andere Dinge, als intendiert wurde.
Und hier sehe ich, dass nicht alles irrsinnig oder unvernünftig ist,
was der Kennedy jetzt zum Beispiel fordert, sondern dass tatsächlich er vielleicht
für gesundere Lebensmittel in den USA sorgen könnte.
Da bist du aber jetzt sehr optimistisch. Ich habe da meine Zweifel.
Da wird sich dann am Ende schon das Bestechungssystem der Industrie durchsetzen.
Ja, aber Hitler war halt auch seiner Zeit echt voraus mit seinen ganzen Nichtraucherkampagnen.
Also der war der Erste auf der Welt, der im Rahmen jetzt der Volksgesundheit
Rauchverbote erlassen hat.
Und sich am Ende und am Ende sich durchgesetzt hat.
100 Jahre oder 80 Jahre später so ist jetzt, ja. Aber das ist,
Nichtraucherschutz oder das ist eine Nazi-Erfindung.
Okay, gut, das ist mir egal. Also auf jeden Fall, dieser Kennedy geht gar nicht
und auch alle anderen Vögel, die da jetzt in diese Administration kommen werden, gehen gar nicht.
Und Elon Musk sozusagen ist auch noch auf den Ministerposten.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schreien oder nur weinen soll,
aber ich meine, das Gute ist, da wird er sich vielleicht dann,
Man könnte meinen, dass er sich da komplett zum Horst macht.
Auf der anderen Seite haben sich diese Leute alle schon komplett zum Horst gemacht
und von daher ist es halt auch irgendwie egal. Es ist einfach nur noch eine Zerstörung der Welt.
Das ist irgendwie das, woran die Spaß haben und was anderes passiert da meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Ja, also Musk, genau, als Effizienzminister,
er hat ja da sich selber getwittert mit irgendwie D-O-G-E, Doge,
Department of Government Efficiency.
Das Kryptoministerium wird das nichts anderes.
Genau. Und der Witz ist aber, es gibt das Ganze schon.
Das nennt sich nämlich GAO, Government Accountability Office.
Das ist das entsprechende Ding zum Deutschen Bundesrechnungshof.
Das ist die Behörde, die alle Ausgaben des Staates unter die Lupe nimmt und
eben versucht halt Verschwendung einzudämmen.
Und ich finde es dann halt besonders bemerkenswert,
Wenn im Rahmen des Bürokratieabbaus dann eine weitere Behörde geschaffen wird,
die Dinge tut, für die es eigentlich schon eine Behörde gibt.
Das nur am Rande. Aber ja.
Das andere Ding ist, dass Musk komplett die Komplexität des Problems unterschätzt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das irgendwann auch begreifen wird oder einsehen wird
oder ob er auch dann so zugenagelt ist,
aber so ein Staat wie die USA ist gefühlt zwei bis drei Größenordnungen komplexer
als alle seine Unternehmen zusammen.
Das ist Faktor 100 bis 1000 Staaten.
Komplexer.
Was die Anzahl der Institutionen und Vorgänge und Prozesse und Menschen und
Vielfalt und so angeht. Das ist mal,
Regierung, Regieren ist...
Ja, das mag kompliziert sein, wenn man als Ziel hat, es am Ende allen recht zu machen.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt unbedingt sein Ziel ist.
Weder Trumps noch Elon Musks, sondern die haben da einfach ihre spezifische
Weltsicht und die ist halt so eher im Schwund ist immer Bereich.
Also dann im Namen der Effizienz und im Namen irgendeiner anderen angeblich
klaren Politik und dann ist es vollkommen egal, ob es sich jetzt um Finanzpolitik
oder um Wirtschaftspolitik oder Energiepolitik etc.
Handelt, dann wird dann halt einfach irgendwas durchgezogen und wenn da halt
Leute drunter leiden, dann ist das halt so.
Und ich glaube kaum irgendjemand verkörpert das mehr als Trump und Musk dann halt eben auch.
Und die werden das einfach durchziehen.
Und natürlich wird das dann zu so einer Disruption führen und alles irgendwie
komplett auf den Kopf stellen.
Nur dazu sind sie halt auch bereit. Das kann ja vielleicht auch positive Effekte
haben und ich will noch nicht mal ausschließen, dass es nicht im Teilen tatsächlich
positive Effekte auch haben.
Aber es wird natürlich noch in einem sehr viel größeren Ausmaße negative Effekte
haben und dann natürlich vor allem erstmal die Leute treffen,
die jetzt irgendwie nicht unbedingt im Wählerportfolio liegen.
Und das sind dann auch solche Auswirkungen, die ihnen dann eigentlich auch ganz recht sind,
weil dann halt sozusagen das gesamte demokratische Establishment und Universitäten
und all diese ganzen klugen Leute, die halt Trump dann halt mehrheitlich nicht
wählen, wenn es die trifft, das ist denen dann auch egal.
Haben wir ja schon in Florida gesehen, wie das da läuft.
Dann wird dann einfach mal eine Universität komplett umgekrempelt.
Da werden dann einfach mal alle Lehrer entlassen und durch irgendwelche republikanischen
Vollhorste ersetzt und aus einer ehemaligen weltoffenen,
führenden Universität wird dann über Nacht mal eben so eine total fundamentalistische Scheißbude.
Und ich glaube das ist das was wir sehen werden und dieses Horrorkabinett,
was er dann vorschlagen wird.
Was dann ab Februar anfängt, da die Axt überall anzusetzen, wird eben genau
das tun, aber das wird dann eben auch gezielt sein, um einfach.
Die eigenen Buddies dann zu unterstützen und wer profitieren wird,
sind halt diese voll libertären Silicon Valley Tech Büros mit ihrem Kryptowahn
und ihren Vorstellungen von wir fliegen jetzt zum Mars und wir drehen alles um.
Also das sind ja auch keine neuen Vorstellungen oder so. Das ist ja schon immer da.
Und das ist vor allem eine Gruppe von Leuten, deren in ihrer Weltüberzeugung der Staat sozusagen der,
Kern oder sagen wir mal so, das Sinnbild einer Ineffizienz ist.
Diese Ineffizienz, das ist für sie so ein bisschen wie für uns irgendwie eine Seuche.
Ja, so wie die Pest. Das ist so, ja, dieser Staat, der mischt sich überall ein
und der will dann auch noch Steuern haben und dann will er auch noch armen Leuten
was geben und der läuft ja nicht effizient.
Das hatten wir übrigens auch schon mit diesem Beratertypen der Tories,
der dieses Brexit-Ding im Wesentlichen angeschoben hat. Wie hieß der denn nochmal?
Der dann irgendwann auch nochmal seinen Privatskandal hatte und zurücktreten musste.
Das war halt auch so ein, der diesen Wahlkampf geführt hat. Weißt du,
was ich, wen ich meine? Der nie jetzt ein politisches Amt hatte.
Nicht verrascht. Du meinst nicht verrascht.
Nein, nein, nicht verrascht. Also kein, der jetzt nicht politisch,
sondern nur in der zweiten Reihe aufgetreten ist. Mir fällt jetzt gerade der
Name nicht ein. Egal, auf jeden Fall.
Und der hat halt auch die ganze Zeit von so einer Vision geblockt.
So irgendwie, ja, wir müssen jetzt hier irgendwie die den Staat wieder an Unternehmen führen.
Und diese ganze Vorstellung, Unternehmen wären ja sozusagen der Inbegriff von Effizienz.
Und der Staat wäre sozusagen nur Verschwendung. Und ich meine,
wir beklagen das ja auch, diese ganze behördlichen Verstrickungen,
die Bürokratie und so weiter. Und das ist ja auch irgendwie alles schlimm.
Nur wie du das auch selber schon öfter mal gesagt hast, in dieser ganzen Behäbigkeit.
Und Trägheit, die gebiert ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch wieder eine Gerechtigkeit,
weil sie halt auch irgendwie verhindert, dass Dinge zu schnell in eine Richtung
geschoben werden, die dann vielen Leuten schaden können.
Und es ruckelt sich dann alles immer so über Jahrzehnte langsam irgendwie zusammen
und dann haben wir dann vielleicht unser Nichtrauchergebot in allen Gaststätten
dann irgendwann mal und irgendwann dürfen dann die Schwulen heiraten und irgendwann
ist dann irgendwie auch alles gut und immer wenn man das Gefühl hatte.
Es wird nie kommen, dann ist es dann irgendwann so weit und dann kommt irgendwie
eine CDU-Kanzlerin und sagt, jetzt schalten wir mal die Atomkraftwerke ab.
Also solche Sachen passieren über einen längeren Zeitraum, aber hier haben wir
es jetzt einfach mit einer wilden Meute zu tun,
die bereit ist einfach links und rechts die Axt anzusetzen und alles einfach
mal auszuprobieren und ihnen ist dann egal was ist.
Und da habe ich das Gefühl, dass die USA jetzt auch nicht mehr genug Stamina
haben, um hier mit demokratischen, rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln gegenzuhalten.
Weil wäre das so, dann wie kann es sein, dass Trump für seine ganzen Verbrechen
nicht zur Rechenschaft gezogen wurde?
Wie kann es sein, dass der überhaupt antreten darf wieder zu einer Präsidentin?
Also es ist ja einfach total irre, dass es überhaupt so weit gekommen ist und
das ist ja eigentlich ein Versagen des Staates, genauso wie wir hier ein Versagen
des Staates haben, weil wir es irgendwie nicht schaffen, die AfD zu verbieten.
Also das sind einfach Sachen, die mich sehr beunruhigen.
Naja, es wird auf jeden Fall auf eine Zerstörung oder Schwächung vieler Institutionen hinauslaufen,
von Behörden, die Staatsland verwalten,
von Parkverwaltungen und andere Dinge.
Aber dann auch eben die Lebensmittelkontrolle.
Gut, wird man sehen.
Das kann in die eine oder in die andere Richtung gehen. Aber ja,
dann Finanzüberwachung.
Aber was diese Leute, glaube ich, nicht verstehen, ist,
erst mal, Unternehmen sind grundsätzlich eine andere Art von Lebewesen als Staaten.
Und sie funktionieren in vielerlei Hinsicht auch anders.
Staatsschulden sind was anderes als Schulden von Unternehmen oder Privatleuten.
Und in Unternehmen herrscht aber das Führerprinzip.
Unternehmen sind halt so aufgebaut, dass es da einen Führer an der Spitze gibt
und der hat sehr weitgehende Entscheidungsmöglichkeiten.
Und während Demokratien
so Konsens produzieren und dadurch eben die Kontroll- und Erzwingungskosten
niedrig halten und durch intrinsische Motivation dann auch eine höhere Produktivität haben.
Und das andere Ding ist, wenn du jetzt so naturalistisch argumentierst und sagst, ja,
der Markt regelt das schon,
das ignoriert zum Beispiel, dass es eben so etwas wie natürliche Monopole gibt.
Dass es bei bestimmten Dingen einfach keinen Sinn macht,
Wettbewerb zu haben, wie es zum Beispiel keinen Sinn macht,
irgendwie zwei verschiedene Stromnetze oder fünf verschiedene Stromnetze zu
verlegen und fünf verschiedene Kommunikationsnetze oder ja,
also ja.
Es gibt eben ganz klar Monopolbereiche und die andere Sache ist,
dass Märkte halt auch nicht funktionieren, wenn dort nicht faire Spielregeln herrschen.
Ja, dann funktionieren sie auch nicht mehr effizient, wenn es dann zu Monopolen
kommt oder wenn Rechtssicherheit nicht mehr gewährleistet ist.
Das ist das andere Ding, wenn sich plötzlich herausstellen sollte,
dass in der USA das Geld nicht sicher ist.
Und wenn Trump letztlich wirklich das Nazi-Playbook so durchspielen sollte.
Dann hindert ihn nichts daran, auch von den ganzen Milliardärskumpeln denen
die ganze Kohle wegzunehmen.
Oder zumindest von denen, die ihnen nicht passen. Ich meine,
wir sehen ja, wie es in Russland läuft.
Da wird dann irgendwie eine Behörde instrumentalisiert,
die erlässt dann einen Steuerbescheid und dann werden die Leute halt,
wird der CEO eingeknastet wegen Steuerhinterziehung oder der Eigentümer und
das Vermögen wird eingezogen oder irrsinnige, Irrsinnige,
ich meine, wie jetzt Russland gegen Google, weiß ich nicht,
diese Zeta-Millionen-Strafe verhängt hat mit mehr Geld, als es irgendwie auf der Welt gibt.
Also Millionen mal mehr, also völlig absurde Dinge.
Naja, also das ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es da jetzt dann zu mehr
Raubrittertum kommt, als ohnehin schon.
Und mein andere Ding ist natürlich jetzt Trumps angekündigte Wirtschaftspolitik,
die eben protektionistisch sein soll nach seiner Vorstellung.
Also mit anderen Worten hohe Zölle.
Ich möchte unter anderem 10% auf alles erheben und dann aber auch bestimmte
Produkte wie chinesische Elektroautos dann mit Hunderten von Prozenten belegen,
sodass die quasi damit ein faktisches Verkaufsverbot für bestimmte Arten von
Produkten dann bekommen.
Erlassen wird. Und das kann natürlich,
so eine protektionistische Politik hat das Potenzial, dann auch eine Weltwirtschaftskrise auszulösen.
Das wird man sehen.
Aber was sicherlich auch nicht passieren wird, ist, wie Trump sich das vorstellt,
dass das nicht zu Preiserhöhungen führen wird.
Das ist eigentlich praktisch ausgeschlossen, weil die Importeure werden das
nicht komplett blocken, diese Zölle.
Und wenn durch einheimische Produkte substituiert wird, kannst du davon ausgehen,
dass das teurer sein wird.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man auch sagen, ich meine, China betreibt nun mal
Umwelt- und Sozialdumping.
Das ist das Prinzip, dass wir unsere schmutzige Produktion von vielem an China
ausgelagert haben und dort die Chinesen für wenig Geld billige Produkte für uns bauen.
Darauf hat halt sehr viel auch unser Wohlstand letztlich basiert.
Und wenn man das Ganze jetzt umkehren möchte, ich meine, zum Teil kehrt es sich
um und das wird jetzt gesehen, was passiert, wenn da nur ein bisschen Disruptionen stattfinden.
Aber ja, das kann halt dann auch zu einer spürbaren Verarmung führen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist.
Aber haben die Amerikaner auch einfach zu viel. Denen geht es zu gut.
Nicht allen Amerikanern, die Unterschiede sind natürlich auch riesig,
aber Amerika ist schon verdammt reich.
Wenn du dir anguckst, einfach wie groß die Kühlschränke sind,
wie groß die Autos sind und wie viel Energie dort einfach verbraucht und verschwendet wird.
Das ist enorm.
Also es ist so alles mal Faktor 2, 3 mindestens, was wir hier so gewohnt sind.
Ja und insofern am Ende, wer weiß,
wird das auch dann wiederum irgendwann langfristig zu positiven Effekten,
indem die Amerikaner einfach gezwungen sein werden,
weniger Geld auszugeben für alles mögliche.
Und generell, glaube ich, erwarte ich eigentlich, dass die USA am Ende weiter
geschwächt aus einer Regierung rauskommen wird.
Mit weniger Softpower und weniger Hardpower am Ende des Tages.
Aber zwischendurch kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es auch durchaus interessante
positive Entwicklungen geben wird.
Allerdings unterm Strich gesehen ist es eine Katastrophe.
Oder die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sehr unangenehm werden wird oder deutlich
unangenehmer auf der Welt wird,
davon gehe ich mal aus, dass es infolge eher zu mehr Konflikten,
mehr Kriegen kommen wird.
Aber man wird sehen, wie das läuft. Die andere Sache ist natürlich.
Die Iraner dürften das jetzt nicht mit besonderer Freude sehen, was dort passiert ist.
Was vielleicht man sagen könnte, ist auch was Positives.
Also zumindest scheint Trump jetzt nicht, sich nicht besonders mit den iranischen
Machthabern zu sympathisieren.
Und ja, allerdings für die Palästinenser generell verheißt es auch nichts Gutes.
Also es wird potenziell weiter zu einer repressiven Politik führen.
Trump wird sicherlich auf Israel nicht so mäßigend einwirken,
wie das die Regierung Biden getan hat.
Sondern, ja, und er wird sicherlich versuchen, dann auch noch Saudi-Arabien
und Israel näher zu bringen, diesen Deal dann wieder zu schließen.
Und ja.
Was ja mal ausnahmsweise mal nichts Schlechtes wäre, meiner Meinung nach.
Also ich meine, das ist ja ein Prozess, der ohnehin schon stattgefunden hat,
der nur so ein bisschen ausgesetzt wurde durch den aufflammenden Krieg nach den Terroranschlägen.
Sonst wäre es ja sozusagen wahrscheinlich schon längst so weit gewesen,
weil es gibt halt einfach Länder im arabischen Raum, die mit Israel eigentlich...
Nur gut Business machen wollen und denen eigentlich diese ganzen aufgeregten
religiösen Diskussionen mehr oder weniger egal sind, auch wenn es natürlich
immer so plakativ rausgehalten wird.
Aber wir kommen so ein bisschen sehr weit ab, finde ich jetzt von unserer Perspektive
auf Europa und den Ukraine-Konflikt und insbesondere die Auseinandersetzung mit Russland.
Alles richtig, was du sagst oder zumindest kann ich deine Punkte nachvollziehen.
Am Ende werden wir sehen, was letzten Endes wirklich geschieht,
aber ich habe nicht so den Eindruck.
Dass Trump jetzt besonders gut da drin ist,
so internationale Konfliktlinien gut zu verstehen und befürchte einfach,
dass die USA hier von den doch sehr viel erfahreneren Strategen wie Putin und
sicherlich noch ein paar anderen Despoten ganz gut irgendwie gelingt werden kann.
Also da ist er einfach nicht gut beraten, zumal jetzt auch überhaupt gar keiner
der alten republikanischen Hawks bereit sein wird, ihm noch in irgendeiner Form
beizustehen, weil es einfach keiner sich da die Hände schmutzig machen will.
Sprich er wird also noch mit sehr viel schlechterem Personal seiner Außenpolitik
betreiben und da sehe ich eigentlich die größte Gefahr,
weil einfach die USA wahrscheinlich eine Menge Blut lassen müssen in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also jetzt meine ich nicht Blut im Sinne von Kampfhandlungen.
Sondern eben so in ihrer, da wo sie eigentlich stark sind.
Du hast es schon gesagt, ihre Softpower und in gewisser Hinsicht auch ihre Hardpower
wird dort Schläge entgegennehmen müssen und das ist natürlich auch schlecht für uns.
Weil wir uns natürlich in unserer westlichen Allianz eigentlich ja immer ganz
wohl gefühlt haben und so die Amerikaner als Verteidiger der Freiheit und der
Garant der Stabilität und so weiter gefeiert haben,
was uns ja auch dazu gebracht hat, unsere eigenen Rüstungskräfte.
Ausgaben so zurückzufahren und zum ewigen Blümchenwiesen-Pazifismus es da gemütlich
gemacht haben und jetzt so ein bisschen blöd dastehen und nichts in der Hand
haben, mit dem wir irgendjemand abschrecken können.
Und auch nicht genug Produktion haben und am Ende auch noch nicht mal genug
politischen Willen haben,
um auch nur irgendwie nennenswert irgendwas zu unternehmen gegen diese Landnahme
und diesen russischen Imperialismus und es offensichtlich auch hier erst richtig knallen muss,
bevor irgendjemand merkt,
wohin die Reise geht.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass es uns allen zu lange zu gut gegangen ist,
dass wir uns bestimmte Dinge vielleicht gar nicht mehr jetzt so vorstellen können.
Und vielleicht auch die, ich meine, ich habe ja jetzt mit meinen fast 60 Jahren angefangen,
Ja, viele Dinge gesehen, so erlebt.
Aber du ja auch noch, also vom Kalten Krieg dann, ja,
über dann die 90er Jahre, die dann so ein Aufbruchszeitalter und Ende der Geschichte
und Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen.
Bis hin zu den letzten Jahren,
wo es angefangen hat, ungemütlich zu werden auf der Welt.
Und die USA, die Spaltung dort, die hat schon vor Trump eigentlich begonnen.
Ja, deutlich. Tea Party und so weiter. Das ging schon vor 20 Jahren los.
Und Sarah Palin und so, diese ganze Bewegung.
Und Trump hat die halt sich wunderbar zunutze gemacht, hat die halt wunderbar
gekapert und ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die Ursache, sondern eher so ein bisschen Brandbeschleuniger.
Und hat vielleicht das ein oder andere beschleunigt.
Aber mir ist unklar,
wie jetzt dieser Prozess umgekehrt sich umkehren soll oder langsam umgesteuert werden kann,
ohne dass es zu einem Knall kommt oder zu einer Auseinandersetzung oder zu Konflikten,
die dann vielleicht wieder für Besinnung sorgen, aber normalerweise ...
Ja, ist das dann eher ein Umweg oder wenn es halt dann zu massiven Unruhen,
Auseinandersetzungen, mehr Krieg kommt,
zu Krisen, krisenhaften Anpassungserscheinungen.
Wann kommt das denn her?
Das ist so Soziologen-Sprache, so Max-Planck-Institut für Sozialforschung unter anderem, ja.
Ja, und diese krisenhaften Anpassungserscheinungen, bis man dann wieder da ist,
wo man irgendwann mal war in seiner Entwicklung, kann das dann länger dauern.
Also wir sagen, Krieg führt uns erstmal einer Lösung nicht unmittelbar leer,
sondern sorgt dafür, dass erstmal mehr kaputt geht und auch mehr Verrohung stattfindet
und mehr Hass und Angst in der Welt ist,
bevor sich das dann vielleicht wieder umkehrt, weil die Leute irgendwann einsehen, okay,
das war vielleicht jetzt doch nicht so geil, was wir hier irgendwie veranstaltet. haben.
Aber ja, da kann man nur hoffen, dass das nicht wieder sowas erfordert wie den
Zweiten Weltkrieg, der dann die halbe Welt in Schutt und Asche legt.
Ja. Ja.
Ich denke an der Stelle sollten wir es jetzt auch erstmal beenden.
Also das war jetzt ein etwas düsterer Ausblick. Ich meine, das teilen wir sicherlich
auch mit vielen anderen, die diese Situation kommentieren.
Es ist gerade jetzt nicht so einfach,
da viel optimistisches Potenzial rauszuquälen aus den Geschehnissen.
Ja, was man feststellen kann ist, es werden sich nicht Dinge wahrscheinlich
von einem Tag auf dem anderen ändern.
Und es wird auch nicht alles so laufen, wie Trump sich das vorgestellt hat und
er wird sicherlich auch nicht alles tun und tun können, was er sich vorgestellt hat,
aber die Situation ist halt extrem volatil und es hat jede Menge Konflikte zu erwarten,
innenpolitisch in den USA, wie auch außenpolitisch überall auf der Welt.
Und ja,
Ja, also ich bin leicht beunruhigt, so muss ich sagen, von dem,
was die Zukunft bringen wird.
Aber ich bin nicht jetzt verzweifelt, also noch nicht.
Nee, das sollte man auch nicht sein.
Immer wenn man denkt, es geht nicht weiter, dann tut sich meistens auch schon
wieder ein interessanter neuer Aspekt. Denn all diese Dinge gehen ja nicht nur in eine Richtung.
Die Wellen, die brechen wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade mit großer Energie an die Ufermauer,
aber auch das erzeugt irgendwann wieder einen Rückstoß und es ist immer sehr
schwer vorherzusagen, wie die Dinge weiterlaufen.
Von daher ist es halt nicht komplett hoffnungslos.
In der Ukraine, denke ich mal, dürfte die Stimmung jetzt allerdings nicht gut sein.
Das ist sicherlich für viele ein Schock.
Nicht, dass sie nicht auch in irgendeiner Form sich darauf vorbereitet hätten
auf politischer Ebene, das denke ich schon.
Aber für die Bevölkerung ist das sicherlich jetzt.
Nichts, was jetzt besonders viel Kraft in die Gesellschaft schiebt.
Das muss erstmal weggesteckt werden. Aber sie werden auf jeden Fall weiter kämpfen
und deswegen müssen wir halt auch weiterhin die Ukraine unterstützen und ehrlich
gesagt müssen wir jetzt halt eigentlich dazu übergehen,
sie noch mehr zu unterstützen, als wir es bisher getan haben.
Weil bisher war das alles sehr mit halber Kraft und das hat uns in diese Situation
gebracht mit mehr Energie.
Wir haben dieses Problem vielleicht schon längst losgeworden,
davon bin ich eigentlich überzeugt. Aber jetzt ist es halt da.
Ja, vielleicht führt es ja dazu, dass Europa enger zusammenrückt.
Das wäre meine Hoffnung. Aber du schon sagst, vielleicht kristallisiert sich
dann auch eine Gruppe heraus in Europa,
die dann ja mehr Verantwortung für die äußere Sicherheit übernimmt,
als das bisher der Fall war.
Und ich meine, das zeichnet sich ja jetzt auch schon ab. Wir hatten Polens militärische
Stärke ja schon geschildert.
Ich denke, es ist in den letzten Monaten auch klar geworden,
dass wir so eine, ich sag mal.
Osteuropäisch-baltisch-skandinavische Achse haben, die auf diesen Konflikt ganz anders blickt.
Man könnte Niederlande noch ein bisschen mit reinnehmen, aber vor allem die
Polen und die Balten sind halt auch schon breit.
Zu diskutieren, Truppen in die Ukraine zu entsenden.
Also diese Idee mit NATO-Truppen in der Ukraine,
das ist jetzt auch nicht aus dem Nichtshäpfel vorgeholt worden von Zelensky,
sondern es gibt da auch schon klare Wortmeldungen aus den baltischen Staaten,
dass sie sich sehr wohl an so etwas beteiligen würden.
Und auch in Polen herrscht die Überzeugung, dass man im Zweifelsfall lieber
noch in der Ukraine schon gegen die Russen kämpft, als das dann erst auf eigenem Territorium zu tun.
Also die sind da einfach im Kopf schon ganz woanders,
während wir uns hier immer noch so hinter unserer alten, unseren eisernen Vorhang
sozusagen zurückziehen und sagen, naja, es wird schon nichts passieren und es
ist ja alles ganz weit weg und was haben wir denn damit zu tun?
Und Hauptsache Frieden im Sinne von hört doch mal auf zu kämpfen wir wollen
hier in Ruhe Fernsehen gucken das ist halt wirklich so diese feige Grundhaltung,
aber du hast es in Finnland anders und dadurch hast du halt auch auf.
Dänemark und Schweden und Norwegen sehen es entsprechend anders und deswegen
sind die halt in ihrer Unterstützung auch so total, weil wenn man sich mal anschaut, was die halt,
kontributieren zu dem zu der Verteidigung der Ukraine, gemessen an.
Dem Bruttoinlandsprodukt einer Person das deutlich mehr als Deutschland leistet.
Egal, da können wir uns jetzt hundertmal im Kreis drehen. Ich würde sagen,
wir beenden es an dieser Stelle.
Das war jetzt, sagen wir mal, auch sehr kurz nach dieser Entscheidung.
Das sind alles erste Gedanken, die wir haben.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen jetzt
der Fallout noch weiter auf alle absenken wird und neue Aspekte kommen.
Wir werden sehen, welche Auswirkungen das auch auf Europa und auf Deutschland hat.
Während wir hier aufnehmen, hat irgendwie unser Kanzler den Finanzminister entlassen.
Mal gucken, was das jetzt wieder bringt.
Also das diskutieren wir jetzt aber nicht, sondern da schließen wir jetzt erstmal,
was da jetzt schon wieder passiert ist.
Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es von uns, von UKW und.
Wir leben in interessanten Zeiten.
Wir leben in sehr interessanten Zeiten. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Tschüss.